Laut NASA werden wir in den nächsten Jahren
Aliens finden.
Und die NASA will die erste Weltraumorganisation
sein, der das gelingt.
Damit sie dabei erfolgreich ist hat sie jetzt
eine neue Organisation gegründet, um schneller
erfolgreich zu werden.
Sie hat jetzt das Center for Life Detection
Science (CLDS) auf deutsch das Zentrum für
die Erkennung von Leben ins Leben gerufen.
Was die NASA damit vorhat?
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Sciencevideos
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s.
Herzlich willkommen.
Die NASA scheint sich immer sicherer zu sein,
dass wir tatsächlich schon bald auf außerirdisches
Leben stoßen werden.
Um das zu beschleunigen hat sie jetzt das
Center for Life Detection Science (CLDS) gegründet.
Dabei soll das Center alle möglichen Prinzipien
abklopfen und Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen
nicht nur der NASA an der Suche beteiligen.
Im Rahmen des Center for Life Detection Science
(CLDS) sollen Forschungsteams der Georgetown
University und der Georgia Tech University
mit der NASA kooperieren und so die Suche
auf eine breitere Basis gestellt werden.
Werden jetzt also Aliens schneller gefunden.
Center Chef Tori Hoehler: “Wir haben jetzt
die wissenschaftliche und technische Expertise,
um diese tiefgreifende Frage mit der Klarheit
wissenschaftlicher Beweise anzugehen - und
wir haben eine großartige Gemeinschaft von
Wissenschaftlern, die bereit für diese große
Herausforderung sind“ Das hört sich nach
einem Ja an.
Dabei setzt die neue Institution auf ein sehr
breites Verständnis von Außerirdischem Leben.
„Die Suche nach Leben jenseits der Erde
kann kein einheitlicher Ansatz sein“, so
Hoehler.
Sprich: Leben kann nach Auffassung von Hoehler
ganz anders sein, als wie wir es kennen.
Und selbst hier auf der Erde gibt es immer
wieder Überraschungen.
Einzeller, die direkt an heißen Quellen bei
80 Grad Celsius von deren chemischer Energie
leben und einen Schwefelstoffwechsel haben.
Sauerstoff ist für sich giftig.
Oder ein Lebewesen, das Quadratkilometer groß
ist.
Der Pilz der Gattung Hallimasch im nordamerikanischen
Oregon erstreckt sich über 9 Quadratkilometer
und ist schätzungsweise 2400 Jahre alt.
Also schon hier auf der Erde gibt es extrem
außergewöhnliches Leben.
Wie könnte es also erst auf Exoplaneten oder
den Monden hier in unserem Sonnensystem existieren,
wo die Bedingungen ganz anders sind, wie zum
Beispiel auf dem Saturnmond Enceladus.
Deshalb definiert Sarah Stewart von der Georgetown
University das Ziel der neuen Organisation
so: Das Leben „so zu erkennen, wie wir es
nicht kennen“ Um das zu erreichen müsse
laut Hoehler so vorgegangen werden: „Um
den besten Erfolg zu erzielen, müssen wir
Werkzeuge und Strategien entwickeln, die darauf
ausgelegt sind, das Leben unter den einzigartigen
Bedingungen anderer Welten zu erkennen, die
sich nicht nur von der Erde, sondern auch
voneinander unterscheiden“ Deshalb will
sich das Team jetzt auf die Ozeane der Monde
mit Indizien für Leben in unserem Sonnensystem
und den antiken Mars konzentrieren.
Beim Mars geht es also um Lebensformen, die
dort vor Millionen Jahren existiert haben
könnten, als er sogar so lebensfreundlich,
wie die Erde gewesen sein könnte.
Aber auch die Suche nach Leben auf Exoplaneten
soll weiter vorangetrieben werden.
Dafür wurde ein Onlineportal geschaffen,
damit auch außenstehende Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschaftlerinnen Daten des SETI-Projektes
auswerten können.
Hier werden ja unendlich viele Daten aus den
Signalen des Weltraums gefiltert, um darin
tatsächliche “Lebenszeichen” zu finden.
Da wird es ja extrem spannend ob Künstliche
Intelligenz jetzt nicht viel schneller auf
intelligente Signale in den Unmengen an Daten
stößt und vielleicht ein kleines Forschungsteam
außerhalb der NASA vielleicht dafür den
besseren Algorithmus entwickelt.
Der erste Kontakt könnte also schneller stattfinden,
als wir denken.
Wie er aussieht, das erfahrt ihr im Video
von Doktor Whatson.
Ein extrem spannendes Video, also deshalb
folgendes machen: Draufklicken, ansehen und
abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!